this hospice in berry provides crucial
end-of-life care helping people and
families when they need it most
but it like every service is now itself
vulnerable as covert staff shortages
grow
today as we stand today our hospice is
open and we're doing well but that is as
a consequence of i have to say
staff volunteers non-clinical staff
absolutely going above and beyond what's
expected of them so we review it on a
day by day basis because it's it's a
changing environment for us all
this hospice is a charity it doesn't get
the same support as the nhs where rising
covert cases and isolation amongst staff
has spurred the government to consider
how to manage if things get worse
on boxing day the nhs in england had
nearly 70 000 staff off work
the shortage has been driven by covid
which now accounts for a third of staff
absences
the government says it is looking at
both best and worst case scenarios when
it comes to contingency planning and by
worst case that is up to one in four
public sector staff being off because of
covid19 and that doesn't just affect
healthcare settings of course it affects
things like council services getting
your bins collected it's affecting the
police force and security and also
public transport
major rail operators have already cut
services and some passenger groups are
warning of worse to come
if coronavirus gets more and more out of
control and the numbers do seem to be
going up and up and up at the moment we
may see more people self-isolating and
off sick and that may mean even more
disruption and more delays and
cancellations i hope it doesn't but you
know
predictions are very hard to make
but the minister in charge of these
contingency plans says more restrictions
are for now not amongst them we don't
think the data supports that at this
stage of course we keep the data
under review but we've seen significant
behavior change as a result of plan b
the
the widespread use of testing combined
with the booster program is the key way
as a country we will we will avoid the
need for further measures
so far in this pandemic we've seen the
army bolster the nhs council workers
re-drafted to collect rubbish and
retired school teachers asked back to
work with cases rising again every day
what is currently a contingency might
rapidly become a reality
catherine of autopsy sky news